a lot par lot s'il y en a
un problème c'est papa il est dans
l'hôpital entre la vie et la mort mais
plus prudent la mostra même toit la polo
faudrait que tu viennes ça fait plaisir
de tous oui moi aussi ça me dit bonjour
à toi ton de gâter les rotules obélix
pop à manoeuvrer tu vois pas où joseph
c'est toi qui me contre chance je suis
pas contre 16 je suis dans le bon sens
je suis dans les salles sans ma voiture
je vais marcher les régimes au gilet
pare balles aujourd'hui tout domoun i
roul à saint cast
ça lui arrive à le mourir mais bien trop
fait trop plus qu est-ce qui va fermer
tonnes avec quino goldstein culé c'est
tout ce que tu as mal dans ce genre
d'accident
by the way we dare il se repose entre la
vie et la mort joseph
qu'est ce que tu m'as dit à bernac quoi
qu'il arrive il a besoin de sa famille
c'est extrêmement important c'est sûr
j'étais pas venir les verts sont la
terre ne peut non plus pas t'empêcher
d'exagérer ça c'est marseille ça toi
aussi tu es marseillais pour les
coutumes et les chemises à carreaux que
tu américaine n'a pas manqué tout ça
cholestérol haoussa manière la fin si tu
écoutes les médecins les petits gars
délai c'est une arme de destruction
massive ce paradis ici c'est par hasard
les collègues n'ont pas manqué les
collègues
albert gros yeux je vais devoir la
moustache fait pas nés fous logan bout
en bout
pendant la guerre
à manquer
c'est nous revenons sur l' affaire qui
secoue marseille ou avec lui ce week-end
les championnats du monde de soupe au
pistou